This topic today is really fun.
Uh, I love the acts of Paul and
Thecla. It is such a bizarre document.
I hope you read it before class as
the syllabus instructed you tube.
It's not an easy document to get into if
it's the first time you've come across
this kind of non-canonical
early Christian literature.
Sometimes we'll call
this stuff apocryphal,
which is just the Greek word for
our hidden. Uh, and we don't,
this is not part of the Apocrypha
that's published in your Bible,
your study Bible. If you bought the
[inaudible], the Bible that I requested,
which was had a,
I think it was the new,
the Oxford Study Bible with
Apocrypha that Apocrypha is,
I explained at the beginning of the whole
semester is Jewish literature that was
published, was written sometime
in the second temple period.
And it's not, it's explicitly
Christian literature for the most part.
So when people don't talk
about the Apocrypha that's
published in a modern Bible,
they're talking about that Jewish
literature that survived in Greek, mainly.
In fact, this was why that those, those
books were rejected by the reformers,
Martin Luther and Calvin.
And the lengthen,
they tended to not use the Apocrypha in
the Protestant Bible precisely because
they wanted to go back to the Hebrew
Bible like the rabbis were using.
And so the Apocrypha although has
continued to be part of the Roman Catholic
Bible in something and maybe
have a secondary status, uh,
is not been part of the Protestant Bible.
But that term Apocrypha refers to that,
uh,
very varying lists because what is
actually even included in that Jewish
apocrypha varies according to
which publication you may pick up,
but some type of pants people will all,
we also use this word Apocrypha for what
they call something like New Testament
Apocrypha or early Christian Apocrypha.
And that's kind of a misleading term
because there's nothing hidden about this
literature at all.
It's always been there.
It's just not part of the Christian Canon.
Some of it is entirely Orthodox,
some of it is rather heretical.
And some of it is,
is somewhere not completely
in tune with later orthodoxy,
but nevertheless,
nevertheless reflecting what was
definitely orthodoxy in its own day.
And so all of this literature is
written in the second century.
Our document today,
the acts of Paul and Thecla was
composed in the second century, uh,
and it was considered quite good
literature by many early Christians.
It just wasn't part of the New Testament
mainly because people knew it was a bit
later of a document,
not so much out of concerns for orthodoxy.
One of the purposes of
my teaching this course,
one of my purposes of teaching all of
my courses is to get students to start
thinking completely differently.
In other words,
you've noticed perhaps that one of the
things I stress in my lectures is how odd
the ancient world is.
Even how odd early Christianity is from
what most of us tend to come at it.
This is because I teach new testament
studies and the history of early
Christianity,
almost like ethnography.
I try to get you to imagine yourself
coming into a culture that's really
different from the culture you grew
up in because one of the, this is,
this is something I think is basic to
religious studies as a discipline and it's
it it religious studies teaches you to
look at some kind of group of people or
an activity or a belief structure that
seems to you initially absolutely bizarre
and you think,
how could any rational person do that?
How could any rational person believe
that and to keep looking at it seriously
and it look at it with enough sympathy
that you actually can see eventually how
it is perfectly rational and this document
today is a great place to illustrate
that because whenever I teach
this document to people your age,
18 to 22 year old college students,
if you read this carefully
and you get into this stuff,
it should be bizarre to you.
These are,
this document depicts young people
who are attracted to a version of
Christianity that forbids
having sex entirely.
It's completely aesthetic.
The Paul in the acts upon Thekla says,
if you have sex,
you're probably not going to go to heaven.
Basically the Gospel mentioned in this
document is continents by which this
document means avoiding sex.
Now that,
and that's going to be bizarre enough
because people in the modern world kind of
had the idea,
well,
why would somebody join any movement
that for bad sexual intimacy entirely?
What kind of draw that did that have
for people? Why did that Gospel succeed?
And what may be surprising to you is
it did succeed in the ancient world.
A lot of people,
especially it seems sometimes even young
people were drawn to early Christianity
precisely because it was aesthetic.
It taught this radical asceticism of
watching what you eat and especially
avoiding sex or if not
avoiding sex entirely,
severely limiting sexual
intercourse and sexual attraction.
So what is it? Why? What is
it about the ancient culture?
What is it about these people that
caused them not only to be converted to
Christianity,
but to be converted,
especially to a form of it that was re
radically ascetic and you to in order to
see why that kind of Christianity
was because that's the actual kind of
Christianity that was successful
in the ancient world. You,
if you were listening to most
modern American Christians,
modern American people,
generally,
what are the two most important teachings
about Christianity in minds of most
Americans, the family, right?
The importance of the family,
and by that they mean the
heterosexual nuclear family,
but even the liberal churches which are
willing to recognize Gabrilino gunships,
they still construe that as gay marriage
or gay just gave versions of the
nuclear family.
So the family's the most important thing
about Christianity and the mind's a lot
of Americans. The second thing
is nationalism. Patriotism.
If you took away patriotism
and nationalism and the
family out of Christianity,
most people in the modern America
wouldn't recognize it as such.
What's odd is that when you
read these ancient documents,
that's precisely the two things that
Christianity attacks this form of early
Christianity was antifamily for the
most part and it was anti patriotic,
so the very, and that was also
people who say, but this was,
this is traditional Christianity.
Those people don't know their history
before 1950 because the church,
the overall Christian churches were never
pro family for the first 1500 years of
its existence.
The Roman Catholic church,
up until the reformation always
had is its official position,
not just popular ideas.
It's official position was celibacy is
superior to sexuality if you're going to,
if you have to have sex,
if you can't control yourself,
you're allowed to get married and have
sex within the bounds of marriage,
but the better thing,
the better virtue would be to avoid
sex entirely for your entire life.
The next best thing is to have sex
if you need to just to make babies,
but in as soon as you have your babies
stop having sex and be a ascetic the rest
of your life.
If your spouse dies,
you are permitted to get remarried.
Most of the time,
but the higher virtue would
be in remaining unmarried
and remaining celibate for
the rest of your life. That was
considered the doctrine in Christianity,
at least up until the reformation,
so the 16th century.
So when people talk about traditional
family values being traditionally the
Christian way,
they're not talking about Christianity
as it existed from the time of Jesus all
the way up until around 1600 and even
then from 1600 until 1950 the ideal form
in most Christianity was not the nuclear
family, but some kind of household.
So in Puritan New England, people
didn't live in little nuclear families.
Downtown ships, the new haven
colony, the Massachusetts Bay Colony,
they were organized into households
that were run by the head of the hat,
the male head of household,
his wife under him,
children under that servants
and free other free people.
Often living in the household also are
connected to the household. If you are,
for example, an adult male,
25 years old in New England,
in Puritan New England,
and you weren't married,
you weren't really supposed to
live alone or with other men,
that happens sometimes, but the the
town fathers and they and these,
these callings were ruled as communities,
not individual people.
The town fathers would want to put
you into somebody else's household,
into the household of another man.
They certainly wouldn't let women,
adult women live separately.
So notice this is not individualism in
the modern sense and it's not the nuclear
family in a modern sense.
These are extended family households.
That was the new England Protestant way.
When did the idea that the dominant form
of the best form of the family was the
nuclear family come about in
popular culture overall? The 1950s
yeah.
So when people talk about that
being the Christian thing,
they're forgetting the vast
sweep of Christian history,
they're just ignoring it.
And this document is a good place to
see why that made sense for people,
especially in the ancient world.
And to make it since for the Middle
Ages and all the rest of the time you'll
have to take another course.
So one of the things I want you to do
is enter into this text as if you're an
ethnographer, an anthropologist, and
try to see how does this make sense?
How does this gospel that
this text proclaimed,
how did it make sense to people
and why was it so wildly popular?
Because it was wildly popular.
First you have to know a bit
about the Greco Roman novel.
I talked about this early in the semester
when we talked about the acts of the
apostles. Greek novels,
um, are very interesting.
There are six of them that survive in
almost whole and then fragments of a lot
of others. Uh, and you can find
these in English translation, Duh.
Help me out.
Teaching fellows,
what's the name of the
collection of the Greek novels?
It's called something like collected
Greek novels. Yes. And is it Reardon?
Who's the edit? Reardon? R. E. A. R.
D. O. N. If you want to dip into these,
just get the collected.
The ancient Greek novels by translated
by Reardon are are edited by Reardon and
read through some of them.
They're very entertaining.
One of the things that typical plot
is a woman of high elite status.
These are usually are people, young
people of elite families in classical,
they're usually set in classical Greeks,
although they're not written until
the first century, second century,
third century of our era,
but there often are set
in a more classical Greek
setting and our upper class
people, a young woman who's
of of an upper class family,
falls in love with a young man who's also
from an upper class family and s and a
few of the great novels. They actually
get married and have a little honeymoon,
a brief honeymoon period, and then all
hell breaks loose and something happens.
In some cases they don't
even get to consummate their
love yet because something
intervenes. Usually what happens
is a disaster strikes. And one,
I think I mentioned this too,
that the Keratin carry up Caria Todd's
and clearly and one the husband gets
jealous thinking that his wife has a,
had an affair. He in a fit of rage,
he kicks her,
she falls over and by thinks she's dead.
So he's grieving and grieving because
of course he's still madly in love with
her. They're both Matt and in love with
each other, but they bury her in the tomb,
the big family tomb. That's all those,
the shore by the water of course, like,
and Shakespeare stole mercilessly
from these kinds of things.
She wakes up in the tomb after they've
already sealed the tomb and she can't get
out. And she says, oh,
woe is me. They buried me.
I'll never see my loved one
again in my blah, blah, blah,
blah pirates who happen to be outside.
There's always pirates in these things.
Lots of pirates pirates
happening outside. They, oh,
they hear her crying and
they break into the tombs.
They were just gonna do
a little tomb robbery.
They were intending to tomb tomb robbery,
but they find this living maiden
[inaudible] anymore. She's had sex now,
so she's a maid not made anymore.
But anyway,
she's a beautiful young woman and
they decide, well, great, this,
we can get more for her than from
the stuff in here, will kidnap her,
sell her as a, as a, into slavery
at some other port. And they do.
So they take her off,
they take her around over to Asia minor,
modern day Turkey and there they
seller to this wealthy man. He,
he falls in love with her.
So he decides to marry her and then
something else happens and they go to the
king of Persia and the King of
Persia falls in love with her.
So he steals her away from the God,
the Greek Guy,
and then warfare's
breakout and her husband,
as soon as he finds that
she's been stolen away,
he starts traveling all
around the Mediterranean
looking for her and he'll get
just to Alexandria in Egypt the day after
she been sold off to slavery someplace
else.
So these to traipse around
the Mediterranean looking
further because they're
madly in love and you want
to consummate their marriage.
And of course everybody falls in love
with both of them no matter where this
young woman goes, every, every
man around falls in love with her.
And that's caused problems all over the
place. Of course, in the ancient world,
everywhere the young man goes,
everybody falls in love with him,
both women and men because that
was quite common. And so, you know,
they both have all this eroticism.
So they're,
they're describing their
beauty all the time.
Usually there's someplace in the
novel where they can get naked,
where somehow the plot happens,
where she stripped because she's going
to be punished or he's stripped because
he's going to be crucified or
something has happened. And the, the,
the story kind of concentrates
on how beautiful their
bodies are. In other words,
the whole novels are about being faithful
to the person you loved in your youth
because they both try not to have sex
with anybody else, if they can at all.
Do that.
Be Faithful to your lover from your youth.
But the but the erotic drive is
just all the way through the novel.
The novels are full of eroticism
and the eroticism of the eye.
So this acts of Paul and Thecla is so
wonderfully like those things because it
also uses eroticism.
Did you notice how often Thekla is
portrayed as gorgeous and even stripped so
you can,
you as the voyeuristic reader can imagine
her naked body before she's thrown
into the vat of killer man eating seals.
You remember that scene
and so the erotic is here in this text,
but the erotic is used
to the opposite purpose.
The erotic is used to actually
teach you to avoid sex.
So the,
to really read this text of the ax effect,
it helps with you know that the way
these ancient Greek novels often work.
So let's look at the texts now and
I'll show you some of these things.
Look at paragraph 18 I don't
know if you have the pages,
but your text,
there are a couple of different
additions that I've used this class.
I don't know which one I had
for downloading with you,
but I'm going to not talk about
page numbers most of the time.
But paragraph numbers,
because the texts are all divided
up into paragraph numbers.
So in paragraph 18
Oh, where is it? Look,
it's a faculty has gone off to prison.
So firstly,
of course the story goes that she hears
Paul preaching in our hometown and she
falls in love with him just from
hearing us preaching. Not the text,
doesn't really say she falls
in love with him. Right?
But it describes her as being unamortized
of Paul, at least of his gospel.
And so for example,
she goes to visit him in prison.
He's been thrown in prison
because wherever Paul goes,
he gets into trouble
with the men of the city.
And it's always the men of the city
he gets in trouble with. Right?
And it's because he's teaching wives not
to have sex with their husbands anymore.
Well,
this gets the guys upset and he's teaching
unmarried women not to get married
and young men not to get married.
Well, if you, if you don't get married,
don't have sex,
you're not going to have children.
You're not going to have babies. And
the households will hold all fall apart.
So Paul is,
it gets in trouble precise because of
his auntie household anti-sex message
because the men of the city know
full well that if you don't have sex,
you don't have households,
you're not going to have a
city civilization's going
to fall apart in their
views. So, so he's arrested.
She goes to visit him in prison,
and it says to the jailer,
she gave a silver mirror.
This mirror is in the ancient world,
a typical sign for femininity
and women on tombstones.
You'll often see a mirror
carved when it's a girl,
a young girl who's buried
in that tomb at that term.
She gives the jailer her silver mirror.
She went into Paul and sat at his feet
and heard him proclaim the mighty acts of
God. Paul offered nothing but
comported himself with full comments.
Got and her faith was also
increased as she kissed his fetters.
Uh,
next paragraph down 20, he commanded
Paul to be brought to the judgment seat.
But fet glow rolled herself on the
place where Paul Sat taught as he sat in
prison. So she goes, well, you know,
she's rolling around in the
dust where Paul had set earlier.
Did you ever hear about old people talk
about in very strict Roman Catholic
schools and stuff.
Guys,
we're not supposed to sit in the same
folding chair that a girl had just sat in
because it would be warm and that
was considered a little too erotic.
Yep.
People are screwed up,
write down. Um, she stood
there looking steadily at Paul.
So a little farther Thekla sought
for Paul as a lamb in the wilderness.
Looks about first shepherd.
So all the way through, um,
um, look on the next paragraph. 22,
the young men and the maidens brought wood
and Straw that Thekla might be burned.
And as she was brought in naked,
the governor wept and marveled
at the power that was in her.
I'm not too sure about the writing here.
I mean it,
notice how over and over again in this
text there's something about kissing are
marveling,
are looking and right at the point
where you think that the body should be
what's being referred to.
The author says something like,
power our message.
So there's,
there's a direction toward the body all
the way through this text and then a
diversion of your attention as a reader
away from the body to the Gospel.
But the body is still there, just hovering
right around the edge of your vision.
So the text does that over and over again.
Look at a 20 pair of 25.
Oh, uh, I don't know.
Well over and over again, I'm
not going to go through, uh,
any more examples of that because that
just all the way through the text,
sex is the driving force
of the piece of literature.
Even though the piece of literature is
going to try to teach you not to have sex.
And so there's also desire and passion
all the way through. But as I said,
the main message of the text is don't
have sex. So look at paragraph five.
This is where Paul is giving his own
version of the beatitudes that's you're
familiar with from Matthew and Luke.
Paul's version is very different though,
right? Uh, it says in Para Five,
when Paul was entered into the house of
Vanessa, for us, there was great joy,
bowing of needs break breaking of
bread and the word of God concerning
continents and the resurrection.
Now the word continents there, uh,
is just referring to asceticism
that in this text it,
it doesn't mean just
controlling your sex life.
It means not having sex in Thailand.
So when this, when this author,
this translation says continents, you
read that as complete sexual asceticism.
So that's the main,
the message.
But notice how continents
is linked to resurrection.
So the avoidance of sex is directly
linked to the resurrection of the body in
this text. And these
are the, the beatitudes,
blessed are the pure in
heart for they shall see God.
Blessed are they who have kept
the flesh pure and don't be,
don't be misled in this text.
That means not having sex.
For they shall become a of God.
Bless are the continent for that to them.
God will speak. Blessed are they
who have renounced this world.
For they shall be well pleasing unto God.
Blessed are they who have
wives as if they had them,
not for they shall inherit God.
Now,
that's actually almost a quotation from
Paul [inaudible]. Paul talks about,
you know, having as if you did
not have and these sorts of thing,
living your life as if blessed are
they who have no, who have fear of God,
for they shall become angels of God.
Now,
it might help you to know there that
angels in the ancient world are often
depicted as androgynous, as not being
sexual. Anybody seen the movie dogma?
How many teen movie dogma?
Raise your hand so I can see him.
If you haven't seen the movie dogma,
go rent it.
It's a highly important theological movie.
It's a very theological movie actually,
and if you've seen it,
you remember there's a place where the
angel who's appearing to the woman who's
going to be the chosen one, the
quarter, the Mary type figure, ah,
he appears in her bedroom in
the middle of the night, right?
And she thinks he's there to rape her.
So she takes a baseball bat and she's
gonna try and he's trying to keep,
not get pummeled with the baseball bat.
So he pulls his pants down to show her
that he's an angel. Why does that work?
Because he doesn't have genitalia.
See and that,
so that proves to her or it's supposed
to prove to her, she's just confused.
She doesn't know her angel ology properly.
If she knew her angel Ology,
she would know that angels,
at least in one dominant form
of tradition are androgynous.
So they don't have genetalia are they're
either completely male or something
like that. So that's why Paul says
in this beatitude, you will, uh,
be as the angels of God bless,
let write down their blessed are they who
have kept their baptisms secure. Again,
one of the teachings of early Christianity
like this was once you're baptized,
you're not allowed to send anymore baptism
according to some teachings in early
Christianity would cleanse you of all
the sins you had committed up until the
time you're baptized. Well, what if
you send after your baptism? Well,
there might be other ways get forgiveness
for that, but you're in trouble.
This is why a lot of emperors would not
get baptized into their deathbed cause
they wanted to make sure, you
know, emperors have to sin, right?
They have to kill people.
They have to fight wars.
So the idea was you just
don't get baptized until
right before you die and then
you can go to heaven. So that's what
this is talking about, keeping your bed.
Cause I'm pure.
Um,
some um, in paragraph, uh,
yeah, below that, the last,
bless it bless it.
Or the bodies are the virgins.
For they shall be well pleasing to God
and shall not lose the reward of their
purity. Uh, right below
that in paragraph seven, uh,
the Myra said at a nearby window,
and listen, not in day two,
the word of the virgin life as
it was spoken by Paul, more of a,
she saw many women and
Virgin's going into Paul,
she desired to be counted worthy
herself to stand in Paul's presence. Um,
now look right at, uh, at paragraph nine,
all the women and young people go
into him and are taught by him.
You must, he says, fear one,
single God only and live chastely.
And my daughter also like a spider
at the window bound by his words,
is dominated by a new desire.
This is her mother talking cause her
mother's very upset that Tekla has done
this because deca block off broke off her
great engagement to the richest guy in
town in order to follow Paul. So
the mother doesn't like this, uh,
dominated by new desire and
a fearful passion. So notice,
desire and passion again are
still part of the narrative,
but now they're redirected to a desire
and a passion precisely for celibacy.
So,
um,
the basic answer also the bad guys in
this or antithetic look at paragraph 13.
Paul and the good guys are all ascetic
on paragraph 13.
In fact,
right above that,
this is demas in homogeny is now a bunch
of the names in this document actually
come from Pauline literature
from the New Testament.
So this writer probably knows the
pastoral epistles and some of the other
writings that make up the new testament
because the writer is taking details out
of Paul's life as you'd see in the New
Testament, like these names, for example,
demas has mentioned in the pastoral
epistles as someone who forsook Paul being
in love with the present
world is what it says.
So this writers talk using the same name.
So demons is a bad guy here who
had been a follower of Paul,
but he's now betraying Paul. They
say who this man is, we do not know,
but he deprived.
Young men have wives,
maidens of husband's saying otherwise
there is no resurrection for you except
your main chased and do
not defile the flesh,
but keep it pure so they
know what Paul's teaching is.
This radical asceticism and Paul
links this to the resurrection.
If you're not chaste and pure,
you want experience the resurrection.
Samira said to them, come into
my house, you and rest with me.
And they went off to a sumptuous
banquet with much wine,
great wealth and a splendid table.
Notice these guys who betray Paul are
not only teaching that people should get
married and have sex,
but they're also having great wine.
They're having a lot of food, they're
doing all the anti ascetic stuff there.
Antithetic so the enemies of Paul and
the Gospel here are the antiemetics.
And of course that makes you think,
hm,
who does this look like that
we've been reading lately?
Who says drink a little
wine for your stomach sake?
Huh?
It's the writer of the pastoral epistles.
Remember we saw that the the writer of
first Timothy admonishes Timothy to drink
wine,
not to be an aesthetic and avoid wine.
The writer of the pastoral epistles
teaches that it's the enemies of Paul who
forbid marriage.
So the pastoral epistles,
if this author knows the pastoral
epistles, he's riding against it.
And if the pastoral epistles,
no, the acts of Paul and Thecla,
they're written against this and we
don't know that they knew each other.
Exactly. Those entirely possible
that this author, a new,
some of those new Paul's writings now.
Okay,
so basically what is the problem
of life according to this author,
sex and family?
What's the answer to life?
Avoiding sex and family.
And then you experienced the resurrection.
But that means what is the
deeper problem than that?
This is addressing and here are the
problem. You can see it in paragraph 17.
Okay.
Uh, this is Paul talking to
the pro console, the living
God, the god of vengeance,
the jealous God,
the God who has need of nothing has sent
me since he desires the salvation of
men, that I may draw them away
from corruption and impurity,
all pleasure and death that
they may send no more notice.
Corruption, impurity, pleasure, death.
Those are all linked together.
And here's the clue that helps you
see what's going on with the allure of
asceticism for these ancient
Christians in the ancient world.
This is something also that's
changed radically since the 1970s.
The 1970s changed dramatically.
Uh,
with regard to family sexuality. It's, you
know, the time of the sexual revolution,
the time of the, just people's
attitudes changing completely. Now,
that was kind of,
we went back on that in the 80s with the
aids scare and in the way right wingers
used aids to try to make
sex fearful to everybody.
But that was a sort of reactionary.
The eighties and a lot of the
nights was reactionary, uh,
to the sexual revolution.
But what happened in the 70s that changed
the way people thought about these
sorts of things? Two
things that were big, uh,
uh, impact, uh,
big pushes toward changing people's
attitudes about sexuality and the family,
the women's movement,
which basically was springing out the
civil rights movement and saying that,
that women and men are equal.
The radical notion that women are
people is what feminism is, you know,
so women and men are equal.
Now why was that so important
for issues like sex?
Because the way sexuality had always
been construed up to that point was that
the sex act itself,
uh,
the heterosexual sex act and homosexual
sex acts were always interpreted in the
frame of heterosexual sex.
Heterosexual sex acts embodies in it's
very practices the hierarchy of man over
woman. The idea is man is
superior. He supposed to be on top.
So the preferred position is the
missionary position. And in fact,
in ancient Judaism and Christianity,
it was considered abominable if it was
considered sex against nature to have the
woman penetrate the man in any way.
Why?
Because they considered it only natural
that the man is the superior one and he
penetrates the woman May.
It's mailed to penetrate it's feminine
to be penetrated and they believe that
whether it was a penis,
vagina, vagina, sex,
or whether it was oral sex or whether
it was anything in any kind of sexual
intercourse in the ancient world,
and this continued pretty much all
the way until the modern world,
the man is superior masculinity,
superior and femininity is inferior and
that's embodied in the sex act itself
and the superiority of the penetrator
and the inferiority of the penetrate Ted.
That's why the word fucked is a bad thing.
Although actually most of us think
actually doing it is not such a bad thing.
But why is it that in our,
in slang and Cursewords,
we still use words like that sucks.
And a lot of people don't even know
that it verse to sex. But yeah,
of course it refers to sex and
something that sucks is considered bad.
It's not considered bad to be sucked.
Something that fucks is not bad.
It's considered bad to be fucked.
Why is that? Because our entire
history has penetration is superior.
It's in theory or to be penetrated.
It's embodied in our culture that
started to be challenged. Now see,
you may find this kind of weird that
I'm insisting so literally on the
interpretation of these words,
because that may not be the
way you use them or hear them.
What I'm saying is that if it's not the
way you use them or hear them is because
society has changed radically
in the last 30 40 years.
So no longer is it automatically
considered that women
are inferior to men and
therefore the sex act is not considered
to be one that necessarily has to be
hierarchical. The reason that
people in the ancient world,
if they opposed homosexual sex,
the reason they opposed it is they
assumed that one man would have to be
penetrated by another man.
And that was horrible because
it disrupted the hierarchy.
Or a woman would have to penetrate
another woman and that also disrupted the
hierarchy. It has to be man, woman,
because the hierarchy is man and woman.
And every sex act was supposed
to imitate that hierarchy.
That changed radically beginning in the
70s the other big thing that changed was
the pill.
Now of course there had been contraception
for years and years before that for
time and memorial people,
human beings have always known how to
avoid getting pregnant to some extent.
But with the 70s and the wide
availability of contraceptive,
uh, medicines, drugs, the odd,
it was much more easy to have heterosexual
sex and not be worried about whether
you're going to get pregnant before that.
And this is also something that people
your age just have trouble getting
through your heads.
Before that every time a
woman had heterosexual sex
of any kind of penetrated a
way, no what normal way people
were having sex, she was,
she had to at least be partly worried
that she was gonna get pregnant.
Every time a man and a
woman had sex pregnancy,
the danger of pregnancy was always
there hanging over their heads.
They can accept it and they could want it,
but if they didn't want it,
it was still hanging over their heads.
That's not true for us today.
We have enough reliable
means of contraception that
we can pretty much decide
that we want to have sex just for fun,
without worrying about pregnancy.
These two things,
the women's movement which challenged the
basic hierarchy of the sex act and the
availability of contraception,
radically changed notions
of sex because before that,
and here's what goes back
to the ancient world.
I've mentioned this before and we were
talking about other texts already,
but just to review for the ancient mind,
sex was simply one cog in a wheel because
why did you have sex toward in order
to make babies,
why did you need to make babies?
Because so many of them
were dying all the time.
I think I've told you this
statistic that in the ancient world,
for the population of the Roman empire,
just to remain stable,
not for it to grow just
for tremendous stable.
Every woman who lived to childbearing age,
which was considered about
14 in the ancient world,
had to have an average of five childbirths
for the population remain stable.
Think of this girls,
every one of you would have to have chuck
at least five childbirths on average
just to maintain the population that
just shows how many people died in
childbirth, how many women died giving
childbirth, how many infants died.
So in people's minds,
every birth was automatically linked
in their mind to death because it was a
dangerous thing.
People died often in child childbirth
and women died giving birth and all in so
many children died and they also knew
that they had to keep having babies or the
population would shrink. And populations
in the ancient world did often shrink.
And that was dangerous because
whole cities could disappear.
Whole populations could disappear if
the birth rate didn't remain high.
So every birth was considered
cause you had to have babies.
Why'd you need babies?
Cause people are always dying.
So the idea was you have sex,
birth,
death, decay, sex, birth, death,
decay, sex, birth, death, decay.
That's all what life is.
Life is a big circle of sex,
birth,
death and decay.
And now comes Christianity,
which says we're going to
teach you to break that cycle.
How do you break the cycle? Will,
it may not be intuitive to you,
but this seemed to be intuitive to a lot
of ancient people who incorporated this
into their teachings about the
Christian said stop it at sex,
break the cycle. It's sex. And that's
why these texts is not intuitive to us.
But it's intuitive to them that if you
want to stop that cycle of sex, birth,
death and decay, the easiest place for
human beings to stop it is that sex.
Just break the cycle, don't
have sex, don't have childbirth,
don't have death.
And of course they believed they had an
answer for the death part because they
believed with Christianity, with Jesus
Christ, you would have resurrection,
the body would be raised.
So you don't need childbirth anymore.
If you're a faithful Christian,
you'll live forever anyway.
So you don't need to replenish the
population by having more babies.
All the people who are Christians who
come into Christ will be resurrected and
we'll live forever. So there's no
need for more and more population.
So the reason that these texts,
and this is not the only one,
this is just one places where it's very
clear because whenever Paul talks about
sex,
he also talks about death.
He talks about corruption and
he talks about resurrection.
So this text very clearly pulls all
of these issues in to one another.
So the basic sensibility of this
gospel that we moderns don't have,
and you have to imagine
yourself back into their world,
is the radical availability of death
and the linkage of death with sex and
ancient mines. And then also the linkage
of all these other things with um,
uh, sexuality and death and
corruption. Christianity said,
stop the cycle.
It's sex and you get rid of death.
Radical as that may sound to
us. The problem, of course,
is in this text,
the people who find that message
very compelling are young women.
A lot of wives, although not
all of them, and even young men.
Also people who find that message
compelling happen to be lionesses.
The female animals also like this
message, right? Who are the ones who,
who gang up on the bad male animals who
are trying to attack Thecla in the arena,
the female lion.
So that this the,
the text is set up as an opposition.
But now notice I said young men are
also included in the good side of this
sometimes. So what is it? What is
the opposition to Paul's Gospel?
It's not men versus women,
right?
What does the opposition,
it's male heads of households against
everybody else who would be members of
their household.
The people who oppose Paul the most in
this text are male heads of households.
Precisely because they recognize that
challenging the centrality of sex and
childbirth will in itself challenged
their household and their system.
You have to have sex in childbirth in
order to maintain the household structure.
So they're the ones who are against Paul.
So Paul appeals mostly to women and
young people already think I read part of
that in paragraph seven.
The women and the virgins are going
to hear him in paragraph nine.
Uh,
it talks about women and young people
go into him and enter, taught him.
So that's who it is.
And then 12,
I read this passage,
paragraph 12,
he deprives young men have
wives and maidens of husbands.
So he's depriving the men who want to
continue the household structure and
that's why they are opposed to him.
MMM.
Notice and page 20 s paragraph 26 and 27
where is it?
Yeah, I'm 26. This guy, um,
sees Thecla in a different place.
Uh,
Alexander Sees Tekla and he falls in love
with her as is typical in these kinds
of texts is always the beautiful woman.
Every man, no man can resist them.
But so he says he wants to marry her.
I did not wish to marry the Maurice.
I've been cast of the city taking
hold of Alexander. So here's,
she takes all this guys at,
or she ripped his cloak,
took off the crown from his head
and made him a laughing stock.
But he partly out of love for her and
partly in shame at what had befallen him,
brought her before the governor.
And when she confessed that
she had done these things,
he can dinner to the beasts.
But the women were panic stricken and
cried out before the judgment seat and
evil judgment,
a godless judgment.
But Thekla asked the governor that she
might remain pure until she wants to
fight with the beast. And then she
says, just don't make me have sex.
I'll be glad to go into the
arena and fight with a beast.
Just don't make me have sex. Uh, Richard
Rouse, a woman named [inaudible],
whose wife had died,
took her under her protection and
found cover when the beast or led in
procession,
they bounce her to a fierce lioness.
And the Queen Trifacta followed her
and his Thekla sat upon her back.
The lightness licked her feet
and all the crowd was amazed.
So you had this situation where, what's
the problem without, what is Alexander?
He's shamed. So in this honor,
shame system of the ancient world,
this is also important point.
Male heads of household
occupied the position of honor.
And by tearing his clothes, by knocking
his crown off, she shames him in public.
And this of course totally disrupts this
hierarchy of the man over the woman.
And that's part of what's going on here.
Women who refuse their role as
child bearers, as sex objects,
shame the men who play put them
in that role. And so that's what,
that's what the conflict is about,
is shaming men and rebelling
against the household structure.
And then of course there's the salon
solidarity of women with everybody else.
Notice in this,
Paul himself is rather ambiguously placed.
He's a man.
So what is Paul's role in all of this?
I think it's interesting that Paul
doesn't come across in this text,
at least in my reading,
as being a totally positive character.
It praises him, of course, in prison, some
as a man of God. But notice the thing,
some of the things that Paul does,
Paul refuses to Baptizer.
Remember it. She has a bad ties herself.
This is that wonderful scene, right?
Where she's being a martyr.
They're trying to mart her again and they
stripped her naked and then they have
this big vat of killer man eating seals.
Yes,
that's what it says. You probably didn't
even know there were a man eating seals,
but there were in the ancient
Mediterranean world. So she's an,
instead of waiting to be
thrown into the VAT of Manning,
says a lightening bolt comes down
to this guy strikes the water.
I'm all a man eating seals die.
So God saves her.
And then though not to let those seen
finish, she, she's already, there's water.
She's tried. She's asked Paul to her
at once and he didn't, wouldn't do it.
So she throws herself into the
water and bad times is herself.
This is a woman. You're not supposed to
let women go around baptizing themselves.
That could just disrupt
all kinds of stuff.
So Paul at one point says he
doesn't even know her in one place.
He refuses to Baptizer.
Paul [inaudible] and Paul gets in trouble.
He runs off and hides and caves and stuff.
Who's the big hero of this story is not
Paul. He's, you know, one of the heroes,
but it's really thet club.
It's this woman who totally refuses
to accept her role as a baby factory,
and that's what women are in the
ancient world. Baby factories.
She totally refuses to accept that role.
She baptizes herself when
Paul had states the Baptizer,
and then of course at the very end of
the document, remember how it ends.
She goes to Paul and she says she wants
to be a follower of not, and he kind of,
again, he kind of just says, no, go.
You don't leave me alone. You know,
Paul is not all that great with her.
What does she do first?
She inherits a bunch of money. Another
rich woman left her a ton of money,
so she's able to support
herself and her mother,
I guess she and her mother and by the
end of the thing are now in good terms.
I mean, if you survive lightening and
mandating seals and God saves you,
maybe your mother will like you
better and let you not get married.
But so she supports herself financially
through an inheritance that she gets
from another woman. And then
what did she do? She, you know,
she cuts her hair short. She dresses like
a man. She actually becomes an apostle.
She goes off to spread the
message of this ascetic sex,
avoiding antifamily Anti Household
Gospel that she got from Paul Thek Club
becomes her own apostle,
spreading the message and notice what kind
of gospel she's going around teaching.
This is not pro family. This is not
patriotic. This is not nationalism.
This is putting all your eggs in
the basket of the Kingdom of God.
That's the only thing worth
living for is the Kingdom of God.
And how do you get into the Kingdom of
God by avoiding sex and avoiding the
household. That's how you get
in and enjoy it and remain.
How do you avoid death
by being resurrected?
So this message is a very erotic
message in a sense. It's not.
It's not getting sexual eroticism or
sexual desire and throwing it all out the
window.
It's actually using eroticism and the
appeal to beauty and the appeal of sexual
desire and it's capitalizing on it.
The author is trying to get you as a
young person who's afraid about death to
convert to a message of the Gospel that
will liberate you from the cycle of
corruption and death that you will get
into if you agree to go along with sex,
birth, death, decay, and that's what
you do if you choose the household.
So it's a radical document. Now the
question is, is this a feminist document?
It's a good question.
It raises Thekla up even above Paul
and it gives a message of liberation to
women, at least from whatever it is
that keeps them down at the time,
which is the patriarchal household.
It gives them a way out of that.
This is one of the reasons that there
were a lot of women in the ancient world
who became nuns who wanted to avoid the
household and you had women running away
from their wives all the time.
Church leaders talk about it. Why?
Because that was you had to get out of
the household if you wanted to have any
kind of independence or liberty,
if you wanted to have any
kind of exercise of power,
you had to get out of the male
dominated household. So Christianity,
the whole strain of Christianity appealed
to precisely those kinds of people and
the author is trying to get you as a
young person to make that choice. Awesome.
Now, the big question is
do you think it's feminist?
Is this feminism or is there something
wrong with thinking about is feminism?
If you're writing a paper this week,
maybe you can talk about that. The other,
another big question is,
do you think this author is actually
attacking the pastoral epistles?
Are the pastoral epistles
attacking this author?
They're presenting two diametrically
opposed versions of Paul.
They both claim Paul as their author.
They both claim to be representing
Paul's Gospel, Paul's message,
but one of them is very pro household
and marriage and sex and childbirth and
the other is anti marriage,
anti household, Auntie,
childbirth and Anti-sex.
They both claimed Paul is the author of
their Gospel. Do they know each other?
That's the interesting
historical question.
Or is it just by accident that we have
these two very radically different
appropriations of Paul?
All of those questions I hope you'll
talk about in your discussion groups that
this week and if you're writing papers,
push herself,
answer some big questions in
your papers. Any questions? Yes.
Is it possible or conceivable that
a woman would have written it? No,
it's completely possible is we don't
know who the author was. A our, wait,
is this the one that,
what's the one that Tertullian says?
Okay, so he, he knew, we
actually know that it was
written by a priest, right? Yeah.
So this one wasn't written by a woman,
but for some of the texts in ancient
world, they could be remarried. What?
Not everyone believes or
Italian. Okay. Tertullian,
some people say they're talking was
wrong to tell you as a church father who
wrote around the year 200 in Latin,
he knows the story and he condemns it
partly because he doesn't want Thekla
baptizing herself. She's, you know,
too big for our Britches
and totally Ian's view. Um,
so Tertullian says that they know who
wrote it, and it was a man, man. But,
uh,
Dylan says that other people dispute that.
Okay.
See you next week.